I remember you were doing I think the
Ghost Whisper or Criminal Minds or
something and you said I'm taking a
three-year Hiatus yeah was that a hard
decision or was that something that you
were pretty adamant about if I'm being
honest it was hard because other people
didn't like it it was easy for me but it
was hard for people around me I think
they all were like oh is this postpartum
as she lost her mind what's what's a
combination of both what's going on but
you know I had my daughter a year after
my mom passed yeah so I was very much
like oh the universe is just you know I
consider myself a student of the
universe daily and it has just taught me
a very valuable lesson and that there
are bigger things in life than you know
being on the train of Hollywood and I
needed to just I I just needed to be
well I needed to like take care of
myself mentally and emotionally and
being a mom for me did that